greetings to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
on it for your supplemental needs honors
the way to go with you looking for
shroom tech immune shoot export or how
for brain listen the Mexican chocolate
protein is out of this [ __ ] world
away protein I don't know what it's
called you don't need to know what it's
called just gonna calm right now look at
the [ __ ] deals they got look at the
shakes look at the supplements the beef
jerky whatever you're looking for the
elk jerky I mean they got stuff that'll
[ __ ] go down to calm right now press
in church
BAM and get ten percent off your first
order delivered right to your house
number two you're looking for a gig you
looking for some shin guards a
mouthpiece some boxing love go to Fuji
sports.com right now Fuji Sports has
been around since [ __ ] Jesus Christ
since Jesus took kung fool I saw Fuji
Sport Jesus bought the first D from
[ __ ] Fuji Sports so do me a favor go
to Fuji Sports calm right now president
Church get ten percent off to live it
right to your [ __ ] house you
never saying kick that [ __ ] mealy
Jesus Christ that's some live music ah
you know the I was talking to Dean on
the phone we're talking about that I had
gotten high my to agree with used to go
when I was home and I stayed up late and
I want listening to you know it just was
on the playlist if you want blood you
got it yeah and I just fell to my
[ __ ] like I forgot
and then Gino Cochino maybe the kids
have lost it right yeah said something
like two days later out of the blue like
if he was living I've been going crazy
like sometimes that's why we called you
today because sometimes I'll go [ __ ] I
got a call being Delray and ask him if
he's gonna go to Kansas City with me and
then two days there the phone will ring
and Deena go hey man I'm excited about
going to Kansas City weekend I'm like
wait is it I even call Dean
so I've been slipping like I don't know
what I did in the third grade I don't
lay for lunch hey I don't look at my
weight watch app I don't know what a
[ __ ] lunch like I had to think where I
had breakfast today
yeah and until you today was Tuesday so
today I went over to Marie T because I
don't to do nothin til [ __ ] had a
meeting at 10:00 that was
so I'll about I said let me come read
tea early I went and started writing
before the guy showed up just cuz yeah
you know that's happened being there is
lurking out here with the candles lit
[ __ ] New York how only you back there
for 40 days 40 long days like a Moses
run did fifty three spots fifty three
spots and they got a noose to stand out
a new spot Dan always said that yeah yep
yeah they moved two blocks away 16th and
Irving they're gonna be open I believe
in September and it's gonna be twice the
size and they're gonna have a second
room and do like live podcasts and stuff
so it'll be cool right across street
from Irving Plaza that venue yeah yeah
it's so funny how all these comedy clubs
are gonna open up to 2020 friendly now
yeah they've got five casts I mean been
downstairs the Comedy Store right yeah
no it's [ __ ] like they've gone for it
yeah they will go for it
I can't believe them I can't be mad at
you from going no way man yeah you got
to stay in the game man it's comedy so
hot you can't you gotta have your your
pan and them in the river
well maybe I just haven't been around
long enough but I've known Joey for
seven years isn't it kind of rare that a
new comedy club will pop up and like
everyone loves it like it I haven't
heard anyone say a bad thing about this
damn well they're not new I think I
don't know I think was six years or some
so the other they're new for you know in
a short amount of time but they've been
around for a while and they and you know
I think that they did was they grabbed
on to the guys that are coming up you
know and then those guys exploded like
you know big Jay Ari you know Joe list
mark North these guys all said in are
just everywhere and it's kind of a
perfect storm it's them in the club and
boom you know it's very weird when you
see a music venue have a hot summer
right you know like wasn't like when I
was a kid to palladium but have a hot
summer schedules you know like you would
look at it go jesus [ __ ] christ yeah
and that's what you know the Comedy
Cellar
stand yeah you know I don't know if
anybody even goes to Dangerfield's yeah
I've never I did the seller understand
when you talk to anybody let me go I'll
catch you later dude I have to go
Dangerfield I hear some guys work in
there I just haven't been there I was
where I worked a new room there that
burr turned me on to called Westside
comedy up in the upper 70s up there and
it was cool you know how clubs are there
new yeah you can't even count them you
know you know how many people how many
different neighborhoods yeah normally
just if you had you can have two clubs
in each borough yep hey which you
basically in New York City you've got 10
or 15 clubs you have even 20 clubs from
the village all the way up to one and 80
has gotta be 20 [ __ ] place absolutely
that's the conservative that's that's
way wrong yeah I could be way wrong yeah
Staten Island has to have clubs Jersey
has the stress factory The Borgata
Vinny's catch is cat still in Jersey I
don't know but they're building that
other but new one the guy that has the
in the Mall of America he's building one
in Jersey he's building one in Jersey I
do yeah by John Stadium I'd say yeah
yeah I think he's no he's going more
route 440 or something right yeah I'll
be that's gonna be [ __ ] crazy it's
gonna be great
I'm trying to get the new theater in
Union City oh wow there's a there's a
theater you didn't see that Karlin did
when I was a kid ya know cross the
street from a [ __ ] diner called the
four start9 yeah yeah I've been busting
out BL peas and that [ __ ] since
1974 yeah the best BLT that when I was a
kid they had a tremendous BLT tremendous
chickens just one of those [ __ ] diners
yeah yeah and my mom would stop there
like if everything else failed I could
always count on BLT my mom would wake me
up with a BLT from the four-star [ __ ]
dying it was always a hair in your food
yeah yeah
mr. French fry always got like a long
black hair like somebody back it under
minimum wage Oh [ __ ] tremendous those
french fries but no my buddy works and
he said that to go to Union City back
Center so they getting killed in New
York I could care less
yeah I just don't want to pay $25,000 to
advertise and a theater that's what they
want in New York that was trying to
gouge me I have the [ __ ] eyes on mine
now you people [ __ ] crazy
oh just crazy they are crazy they are
lazy yeah you know you go to these other
theaters and you make a little bit of
money you go to a theater in New York
you're like I gotta sell how many yeah
to do what well most people do but they
do three shows three [ __ ] shows yeah
then I'll make money [ __ ] it I'll go to
[ __ ] Delaware yeah you know me I got
a Delaware I'd rather come home with an
envelope do not come home with no money
at all just I played this day the last
week that's great yeah you made three
[ __ ] by jumping up and down they took
your [ __ ] money where so it's crazy
it really is [ __ ] yeah it's crazy I
remember the theater there and I said my
guys see it [ __ ] that's backstage ago
that's a union chair dude he can you
take it you got a move over here
I just got off stage man I'm sitting
down he one of the Union guys Cheers
where was this huh here's some theater
there in New York by yourself no I was
doing some other guys you know it's just
one of those things I'm just like hey
that's a union Union uh there's one I
sprint music that's what it was you know
it's a union guys which one was that
[ __ ] it's one of those rooms at the
Union guys chairman can't sit there you
know it's it's when I first got into
music one of my first albums but I
turned on was get you yeah as a-- now
it's great one of the first five albums
I haven't bought it's like meirin's
favorite and I looked at him I'm like
what the [ __ ] is this in a cover the
cover is great yeah every norm you can
have this mmm quick Charlie Watts in a
meal so that great snare drum or
something looking at this [ __ ] house
Melissa throw I'm like this is the worst
out this is not what I [ __ ] bought
and I took the
have more put in this case and I put it
in my stack out and I never really told
nobody what I think people come up to me
go to great out and I'm like that guy's
a [ __ ] sucker yeah
and then I forgot what the 2nd i/y about
my ball was that again I was not very
fond of I might the music don't sound
the same what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
yeah this is terrible I was the same way
growing up down the singing to you
horrible this is god-awful
I'll never ever buy a [ __ ] live album
again or something I was done with them
yeah and then I started going to
concerts you know like I went to see
arrows them to Ted Nugent mahogany
Russian you know I want to see Sam and I
think like my by the time I saw ac/dc at
the garden opening up the dead yeah
that's when it all hit me that's when I
got it that they were free-falling just
wasn't a studio I was so used to the
studio version yeah right that when I
would listen to the live version I would
go this is [ __ ] god-awful
this is god-awful and I would like the
guy like you letting you be like it's a
great hour but I'd be like I wanna choke
this [ __ ] because he's mummified he's
gotta be [ __ ] yeah not right with
this [ __ ] guy but no that's what it
was I didn't didn't get any shape the
freedom of live performance I was the
opposite of comedy records remember
there was some where the guys would just
go in the studio and do the bit really
yeah memory that was they were weird
there would be no I know I'd say
anything well you knew there was a lap
track yeah you could hear a lap track
yeah but it was like a t.v lap track
yeah you're like this is kind of funky
and then you get a real comedy record
like a prog wanna go oh this is the [ __ ]
right here you know so to me I live
records was my my pretty much
introduction to music you know like I
got kiss alive to was the first one I
think this is amazing man you could hear
the guys talk and stuff that's what was
weird that was one album that I like
right off the bat see that
it's weird but I like to kiss alive yeah
I like kiss alive by that my 76 whatever
75 I was starting I'm lying
am I starting to get it a little bit I
just didn't I didn't get the song
remains the same
yeah till years later that I listen to
interviews and I heard em on I heard
plant on the that [ __ ] Sunday night
show that was big for 30 years in fact I
bumped into the guy he lives this
through your city Oh 100 years old
Oh the interviewer guy yes I worry about
his health
Rock line or whatever no not rocking
into something rock our stop yet on
Sunday nights Oh what is it and he used
to interview [ __ ] rockers on Sunday
night I loved all that [ __ ] yeah I did
yeah
I love that King Biscuit flower hour
when I heard him on there
I heard Robert Plant tell a story about
that Jimmy Page had done everything he
could talk good talks I'm giving it then
I watched to someone means to say yeah
and I kinda started liking then I went
on a [ __ ] drive out and tear yeah and
the one that really took me over was one
for the road oh man that took me to a
different level and now but then one day
and I'll never forget that some kid
flipped me a cassette
I'll never forget this kid's name and
nothing has a Maps we were in that
emotion we are in the middle they have
studied all for 45 minutes
yeah we were in study hall together and
he had to be like one chair away from me
and he just looked over me look man I
got something for you set unleashed in
the east tom man and I looked at it at
first you know what Judas Priest means
right right Jesus Christ yeah yeah so I
looked at the Catholic [ __ ] silage FES
look and say yeah I'm not listening to
[ __ ] this is Christian rock yeah I'm
like I'm not listening to this yeah no
matter what you tell me
first off I'm too much into Sabbath even
be that
[ __ ] hypocrite yeah it's bad enough
I'm into Zeppelin and Sabbath I'm
cheating on [ __ ] Zeppelin with
Sabbath it's bad enough yeah it's bad
enough I'm cheating on [ __ ] Zeppelin
with Sabbath now you want me to cheat
I'm [ __ ] Sabbath with this other
[ __ ] hypocrite bregma hypocrisy is
this Jesus crisis yes
Judas Priest is unleashed in the east
again you bring that home and you're
here [ __ ] you know you're in for a
surprise you're in Photoshop yeah didn't
town strike I didn't know what the [ __ ]
you think oh my god now now I had a
little bit under my belt there was a
store and you need a city called East
West yeah come what they were really
really known for was their bootlegs
albums out of the garden Oh badass you
did the garden and you got bootlight
east west which is still there but let's
see what East West looks like how the
[ __ ] the head shop two kids dead I think
that the guy who owns it was the band
the Union singers and you said it's
called east-west head shop yeah we had
the same thing record vault guy had all
the live stuff all the time you get the
show I still may have buying Bonzo's
birthday poncho gonzo yeah I got that
one it's got the pig on the yeah yeah
that's so great east-west has been there
since I was a [ __ ] kid 1971 affected
82 yeah look at that look at that look
at that in 82 I bought a [ __ ] a crack
how to make [ __ ] crack crap i
freebase oh yeah it's like a free basis
kid hit Wow before he 995 with the glass
the [ __ ] silk handkerchief
well it says rock and roll superstore
yeah you go to the city you take the
shell lacrosse I'll drop you right off
you go right to 48th Street this has
been there since I was a [ __ ] kid Wow
[ __ ] believable now that's in Jersey
that's New Jersey right new city new
jersey alright Wow store press the store
link there
some poeple company see what it says
there but they would sell that's what
they love shops
same [ __ ] I'll look at that man none of
those [ __ ] other look at the condoms
hazel eye ring look at these bongs and
stuff great that's just the old school
store they have one of those like in the
mall where I lived and you go there and
get black eye posters and you know rock
t-shirts speaking of which what the
poster great hang it behind me to switch
I think so it's so glorious so I know
you guys are both doing great
yeah whatever store might have been for
you Dean does any part of you wish like
you in another universe you're running a
store like this I would give my right
hand oh yeah move to a small city yep
right now yeah where I could get an
office like this and surround myself
with vinyl yeah play music all day and
people could come and buy vinyl and
trade vinyl and then have like a like
you come stay with me for a week if I
could find the small village yeah yeah
in the Midwest somewhere that would be
my retirement job yeah just [ __ ]
chilling with your vinyl friend you know
I wouldn't even do the bongs I don't
want to go to jail yeah yeah do it clean
just for the outlets just by now just
going out to flea markets buying albums
get 3,000 rounds yeah put them out there
it's not gonna cost you a lot of money
now yeah black eye posters you know and
talk to people yeah
the most important thing is to
communicate with people let people let
people let you know that listen I'm
really looking for the first Soundgarden
which works with ultra mega ultra mega
okay I'm looking for that vinyl now you
got a customer
yeah you know what let me call Kiki and
Kiki you know I play something make this
feel you like oh this if they got that
tell me what they want what number one
yeah what's he want - wait hold on let
me call this guy
can I get 450 yeah I'll give you five on
you we just made [ __ ] that's how you
do it yeah yeah and that's people who
want something yeah they want it
middleman Stan you know when you go to
let me
J'son man that place is moving in
Hollywood helm Eva amoebas moving yep
they rake it up in amoeba Oh Dave break
it up you know how I know they rake it
up because they took me for a couple
[ __ ] hundred thousand dollars yeah
they're taking me for some money over
the years I mean there's some I don't
you [ __ ] with on me but yeah I just
don't and I love it I don't care going
in there paying twenty hours more yeah
something there sometimes I'll tell my
wife is she eBay is something yep like I
got but let me tell you something I
found the Cuban I'm one time on eBay for
a yardstick I said let me not buy this I
walked on maybe the next day they had it
for nine ninety five so you know yeah
it's either watch what you'll pay for it
absolutely it's what you'll pay for it
absolutely I go in there and I look at
the the hard to get wall I don't even go
into the peasant area remain with the
peasants I'm there in their meal and
like crazed and and [ __ ] I just go look
at the the jewels I calm up on the wall
like oh [ __ ] this Achtung Baby unopened
or there's divas first album bluevine
large crazy crazy if you're a music nerd
yeah going to those places huh when I go
to those places the think the problem I
has if I was like to talk to the guy
yeah but I know if you talk to somebody
gotta buy something alright you know I
don't mind talking to a guy if he knows
what the [ __ ] he's really talking about
he's passion about it I like even this
guy here in Burbank where I go yep he's
passionate that little white nerdy dude
with the glasses that dude knows his
[ __ ] I've seen them argue people yeah
I've seen them do some crazy [ __ ] in
there I love all that stuff you don't
know like I told people please you call
me a [ __ ] fat [ __ ] thousand
times I probably won't do that until you
get involved with music and get me hot
another caller yeah I get hot in the
college when I was a guy I would get hot
under the collar oh yeah yeah like when
Van Halen first busted out people were
using the van Halen car and I want to
kill those [ __ ]
van Halen to kit my a lot of people
didn't like that one yeah we were all
hatin on them we were always from the
crash and burn dance another way that's
diss yeah once they did know once they
did the poster one that he had exchanged
oh yeah that was that women and children
oh that was it I was so
see I showed everybody posted this is
gonna die you wanna [ __ ] north room
until the valley a debt to attract him
well what ozzy osbourne a hot corner
with this [ __ ] drool but in the
beginning I was I hate it well I seen
them blow they'd blow up my [ __ ]
heroes oh yeah I think about the stage
they destroyed my heroes New York City
how can I [ __ ] be a family's [ __ ]
people what am I your heroes were done
by then blog just up there glazed
yeah just [ __ ] fries what a weird
concert to hell
what a weird night to see it was like
going to see your favorite baseball team
yeah just in last place you know they're
in first play yeah they got the best
pitcher in baseball
you bet him for 10,000 and they just got
beat 11 to 0 funny yeah like that you
could it's so it was such a bad beaten
that you didn't even want to leave the
stadium like your friends have a like
come on come on you like no no I had a
like that's how bad like I've been to
some bad concerts and I was honest
enough yeah a capital C most people go
to something bad but they're their
investment so much oh they just sell
herself it was so it was great it was
great it was the best concert yeah sure
you did would you have heard like the
number one single off of that album
before you bought it or everything was a
secret when he won an album
there's no singles on the bands we're
listening to no no that's it's just you
just bought it cuz you loved the band
you didn't need to hear it
he just went there there was no
streaming or sampling or anything you
just went oh kill her here it is and you
just left immediately with it it's funny
how if I got caught like let's say I had
to do something my mom and Dean what the
al that I wanted I got asked Dean Dean
what is it how is it you're like oh and
I go dude your mom hold now let's go
over there right now
yeah we run over there at least listen
to side one and then I'd run and body
out and I feel shitty like I feel
jinnie because everybody's gonna buy the
album but still I felt like I copied
Dean yeah well it did your own car how
to have your own [ __ ] copy oh [ __ ]
yeah but I always wanted the album first
because I didn't want to feel like I was
copying somebody yeah you know one of
the most brilliant stories I haven't
heard about music believed in that well
the most cultivated stories I ever heard
was Eddie Bravo yeah tell the story
about being a kiss fan and buying a kiss
out and having to sneak in home oh yeah
in front of your friends on the block
because your friends go hey would you
just buy yeah they're so key habit like
run around his backyard and jump the
fence and hide the album on Lou's bed
and then come out you know that's the
kind of love that when people have for
baseball teams yep and basketball teams
football teams and that's a kind of love
like I have like I'd love going to the
record store that's walking it was the
best and everything on the walk with
something like we're going to this place
today but I'm the walk there there's a
place called your Burroughs like oh yeah
it's always sorry this Cuban food yeah
and then we're gonna stop with Dean's
house cuz Dean's got weed so you
wouldn't be there I imagine you'd be
there like 9:00 a.m. and be like okay I
don't want anyone else to get this I
never went in the no breakfast with our
families than me you Dean would meet
like 11 the morning and we'd smoke like
a little joint and ride the bus I would
ride the bus right we'd walk a mile or
two first yeah I always walk tall oh
yeah Iceman we wrote a bus it's exactly
when we bought the AL and sometimes we'd
walked down Bergen line you know you've
walked down it was a little record store
like seventh Street that's why I bought
sabotage yeah the feeling of walking
home with an album and you can't wait
you can't wait you just cannot wait like
when I go to a record that I help them
store now and let's find something like
you know like this guy the church guys
got me Exile on Main Street but when I
found it too one day I almost had a
[ __ ] hot it that I couldn't wait to
get home I was like a kid
I know I'm doing I'm doing a bit about
it right now are you okay I'm doing this
bit where I'm saying like you know when
I was you know now you just stream but I
didn't get to hear music with buting on
a car you didn't hear music till you got
home yeah I mean like you had to get
home because yeah there was no music and
then a Walkman came out later on and you
didn't hear music on the way home but
then the batteries would die and you can
hear music - you could buy more
batteries that was [ __ ] up right I was
[ __ ] your battery start slowing down
people would start [ __ ] dissing it oh
yeah like if you had like a little
ghetto blasters oh yeah you showed up
and you're like oh I got the jam you put
it on a loss of the battery oh yeah you
were disgraced you like chuck to the
neighborhood and she like get out of
here with that [ __ ] boombox what's
the big batteries at question $18
[ __ ] radio what you mean see do
you [ __ ] D cuz I've seen
pictures but I think with every car that
had no like right most cars didn't have
an out orcas Tyler or not even like
Harley well you must be like a fancy car
had a vinyl in it no no no vinyl
Cadillac I had a year where they had a
turntable in the glove box isn't that
crazy
like shock mounted Cadillac or
Oldsmobile one of them look look it up
it looks crazy just wait here was this
look it up hook up turntable in a car
and it should come up and you would open
the glove box and it was all
spring-loaded and you just set it in
there you drive with LPS oh man we gotta
see that crash the [ __ ] car all right
time with the radio imagine like I want
to hear that again type [ __ ] that'd be
great right it happened as there's like
an Oldsmobile or Cadillac they it was an
option right in the glove box and you
could buy it and they would put it in
there there it is look see that look at
that man right in the glove box games in
fifties how [ __ ] it's sick
even retainment systems in the one
Chrysler my god
Chrysler I never thought that all this I
never ever even seen this before I saw
it at a car show and I was like what so
you saw the car with this yeah yeah it
was an Oldsmobile or something and I was
like what the hell is that
look Chrysler Dodge Plymouth so that's
been like one of those big Chrysler's
you don't like lift a soda or something
the 1958 badass dude added in there and
I was like that's in it was shock
mounted I have like kind of shocked so
you hit bumps it just played look at
that dude unbelievable right they said
it was only offered for two years
yeah well that's [ __ ] cool [ __ ] to
have that in your ride ah what you're
alright what's your [ __ ] record I
live record history oh well the first
one I get is kiss alive too
and I I know you know kiss alive - it
came with the tattoos like stickers of
the tattoos it came with a tour book
kind of thing that I cut up and
immediately put on the wall and it had
that famous photo of gene Simmons on the
front that I think is the best rock
photo ever taken its the blue lighting
with the blood coming out that is
stunning
so I got that first and the side four is
kind of a studio record so it's three
sides live and then some new studios and
had like rocket ride baby it won't
surprise beiieve it wants a Brad she
wants a rugged ride what year - kiss
alive - couple 77 sorry had one - 75 yep
right okay okay
77 is that one with the great gold
Spears
yes and the Tigers that's the [ __ ]
kiss they played Cow Palace that year
and that the day they played Elvis died
so the bootlegs called rest in peace
Elvis my walk is 1477 yeah whatever that
day he died that's the day they play
something
yeah s11 is something you notice that I
was a superstar basketball camp
superstar basketball camp Jersey City
New Jersey
August 16th [ __ ] savage that I am and
I got convicted august 15 second degree
burglary 1988 [ __ ] so i got my [ __ ]
these are numbers these are numbers
[ __ ] see what I'm saying I can't
remember what I got convicted I don't
know one I have the breakfast yeah my
weight watch your ass remember I got a
Marie T for yes I did
yeah I remember [ __ ] from them but right
now I don't remember how I'm just going
on my legs just full of bits the last
[ __ ] year I mean notice that I
thought I talked to the doctor about it
yeah
and he goes dog against your 3 year
36,000 mile warranty is up 55 those
belts are worn out and it's funny the
expectations that people have from me I
can not have for me yeah like I had a
dear dear friend of mine female in
Jersey asked me a weirdest [ __ ]
question and I go what would make you
think something like that she goes just
curious most of the guys out with they
don't uh don't work no more oh wow like
[ __ ] just start stops working like that
a friend of mine goes to how about how
you teeth my teeth are great mine are
till people like say that they start
complaining by the teeth only I can play
my mouth [ __ ] vision oh yeah your
vision my vision is good it starts at 44
yep and then it's all downhill after
that
you're [ __ ] too because what happened
with me was I start wearing glasses and
then you're just a little bit here and
there and then your eyes get used to
them and then your eyes get weak and you
need them all the time there's a man
when I was a kid I couldn't wait to be I
want to be a [ __ ] nerd yeah so I'm a
little abdominus and have a like shake
them down put some [ __ ] glasses on me
because you got 20/20 vision yeah yeah
and I'd be pissed off like a
[ __ ] I was like that with that
broken arm I always wanted a broken arm
because the guy at the school with the
cast would be getting all the glory
you know maybe come down god I never
break [ __ ] and I crash hard and not
[ __ ] not break [ __ ] okay are you
stupid oh my god no try to break it
I'm saying like you know like you crash
on your motorcycle you're like [ __ ]
nothing broke damn yeah you want you I
get that sympathy you know you know you
understand your caste right
it's so [ __ ] crazy yeah you tired
took mercy to jujitsu and that song came
on by Queen Bohemian Rhapsody Oh God
and I still remember being in the
seventh grade like that mama mia mama
mia mama mia let me go I'll never forget
being in the seventh grade and a
brand-new blimpy base open oh yeah I'm
like 34th Street in Bergen line Avenue
and you didn't say like a brand new
[ __ ] I could be wrong it was in those
30s and me and my friends are in there
in those days you smoked out of a glass
pipe yeah it was a glass that looked
like a flute the long one and you put
the joint in the hole and then just
called something and you lit it and then
you were then you took your hand away
shot a shot got it yeah get [ __ ] up
yeah so it was like me and Carlos Perez
and my four of us were [ __ ] install this
[ __ ] a seventh grade we get high I'm
gonna walk up there so by the time we
got back to class yeah one we will be as
high we put Visine in our eyes the whole
thing seventh grade seven [ __ ] rate
we got so high and we walked into the
blimpy base we got that you know my [ __ ]
one peeled the original book would be
with wimpy right if not this [ __ ] now
they give me that [ __ ] meat that
somebody lost the leg on the phone not
that [ __ ] this is one blimpy was [ __ ]
they should be a blimpy when I came from
Cuba the corner 86th Street and Broadway
across them in the bank right down that
corner I'll never forget that for truant
officers oh yeah maybe those guys maybe
out shaking they're looking for dudes
listen Aris I'm gonna I played hooky and
I'm gonna boogie base like a [ __ ]
second grade I'm in the blimpy base
living like a doctor I'm having like a
footlong roast beef with cheese with
[ __ ] everything vinegar oil salt
pepper heavier the peddler
yeah [ __ ] - roasted I was a kettle and
he walked in and guess what [ __ ]
uncle Joey didn't in the second grade
all right I offered to buy him lunch
uh-huh that's my [ __ ] home deprived
to me I bribed them when he walked me
home and there's only one 205 West 88th
Street and he made me knock on the door
my mom was all over I loved it just got
home yeah like a few hours before work
in the bar I just yeah she's [ __ ]
closing the bar I'm not gonna [ __ ] ain't
answering and I had a key and I held out
he said you never can go no he goes what
I'm gonna do it Jacko us and they should
be home in a few hours just leave me
here
and he finally left me there Wow and
then I watched him walk down the stairs
and I just left myself in the house that
was it yeah I think in trouble or
nothing yeah but I never forget that
walking up to Rowland what are you
having forward to me buddy what's
already in the second grade I was
already a [ __ ] set limpy's so you
guys skip school when you knew now one
was coming out I skipped school to go to
uh yeah it's always always yeah
guaranteed that was a no [ __ ] brainer
absolutely well as soon as they were
announced it was all over quiche how
much money you guys $18 you know I don't
have much money let me borrow it it's an
investment we're getting tickets we're
gonna see [ __ ] tandoor
but there was two different ways you
could in those days I never stood on
line yeah
I never stood on line okay tell me you
guys would just send it in that's clean
smelling it what you also
ticketron was at different locations
yeah so if you want to be a jerk-off
like everybody else um go to Madison
Square Garden just to be cool I saw you
I get your your or whatever but if you
go to Saint Peter's Prep there's no line
it's like that somebody has a bit about
it yeah there's somebody today I think
it was you about going to get tickets in
the old days when you'd walk in and say
what's the best tickets you got the guy
would turn around and you have like a
box behind yeah yeah man if you'd go
through a box think okay I got rose six
I know I need you know a level like said
like level L and you like L ABCDE ever
th ijkl that's what roadog yeah
that's how you figure out it was 12th
row so when you go to a different
location Linda see if they had better
they used to do these random things but
type in the show and then the ticket
were coming to go it can you type it in
again and a different ticket would come
up and then I got really hip yeah like
this is what happened like first I was
like an amateur but I enjoyed it I
enjoyed going into the city I enjoyed my
buddies mailing in the mailers and
getting four tickets I enjoyed going to
see a concert and then I heard a trick I
heard that right before the show don't
line up they release yeah 50 tickets
they do that and I started doing that
showing up and getting from is it like
their comments no it's called banitsa
band holds like so the band has like 50
holds and then they got how many people
you got there anything there we only got
like 10 and then they released the
others ban and they're always killer
like in family section for the band I
went to see Don Henley on those tickets
oh man with Sheryl Crow [ __ ] in the
Zen farmers [ __ ] I went to see a couple
people with the most notable [ __ ]
time that happened I was hanging out
with this kid named Danny Randy Danny
Randy's the kid I saw the membership
total mafia - wasn't that dude good the
membership good dude
and he was a yeah that he had a
girlfriend that he shipped in from
Brooklyn and he would just tell the same
it was [ __ ] classic why he would be
talking when he'd go shut the [ __ ] up I
told you this thing just sing I think he
was saying so she was a horrible singer
oh my gosh she was gone off why you guys
are talking yeah she would sing like
those disco so yeah yeah give me tonight
I like those type of disco yeah he would
totally shut the [ __ ] up sing sing and
one day he came to me he was main man
Janet Jackson's playing tonight it was
94 Janet 94 95 spoken Janet if killer
record off the foul yeah if if gray
record and
I'm like you I was in Jenna I'm gonna
see [ __ ] Janet Jackson and we went
down and they had nothing and they're
like [ __ ] 7 o'clock he called me he's
like hey man I went back I went to the
mall for my mom and I drew one and then
the guy had like [ __ ] sixth row
should I get him and I go [ __ ] get
those tickets yeah and we went to we
went to fit his green or one of those
was places to see couldn't have been
fillers it could have been Fiddler's
check and see if what Janet Jackson's
tour dates were in 95 94 if she did
Fiddler's Green but when we get the
Fiddler's Green guess who's sitting
[ __ ] in front of me hell it was
either 94 95 fillers green watch this
Janet Jackson Janet Jackson if tour are
the if to another Janet world tour I
don't know what's the whirlpool that's
the Janet world tour what what time of
year was it so it were look she played
in Madison Square Garden in December
this is Colorado Colorado Denver uh the
McNicholas Sports Arena
what year April of 1940 Alma try 95 yeah
try 95 Oh hmm she's that torn right now
not doing too good not going to boy
though she's having problems I like to
see her to [ __ ] the kid the
ex-husband oh yeah
the brothers involved Yeah right she has
a lot of [ __ ] that she's got some
luggage [ __ ] my family luggage Oh
talk to [ __ ] that show yeah like I
read about this I know about this they
have allegations or her giving up a baby
for adoption
oh yeah maybe that from yeah once you go
to the bar at your Barb's yeah that's
like real so now yeah now all the
DeBarge is a [ __ ] looking for the kid
they found the kid Wow they found the
kid
they found the kids somewhere in Santa
Barbara they live in Encino Wow so yeah
I had the kid in Santa Barbara
some like that yeah well so what are you
finding anything huh she was in
Australia Asia in Europe for most of
night
at least for the beginning of 95 so had
we learned before that yeah so I think
it was McNichol Sports Arena and I'll
tell you who was in front of me [ __ ]
Andy Garcia Wow yeah and then when I
told a friend of mine he goes yeah he's
in town they're shooting a movie and the
movie was things are doing Denver when
you dead oh my that fella buddy Jimmy a
beta double to him oh my god that but
Jimmy a bathing yeah yeah no you beta
doubled him that feeling supple phases
an extra but it was hysterical he was
right in [ __ ] the front of me Wow and
I have to like after the first warm-up
bad I think it was Tony Tony Tony oh
yeah they were great record hey listen
to him I said some talk but he goes if
Cubans in never it was bold yeah we
talked he said something unless it
something either they don't let it say
nothing else I was too embarrassed and
then when I came to Atami storm on the
first guy super friend there was a guy
named Freddie asparagus asparagus a big
fat dude how do you really need people
with nicknames I've never won anyone
take a look at Freddie asparagus take a
look at this is Paris is a regular at
the store just his face don't you know
that he was the sweetheart he was an
angel food he was a comic yay wow look
at the store he was in ok yes [ __ ] yeah
you know what is let's say 8 million
ways to die he anything Andy Garcia did
early on and he would put him into oh
yeah I know that guy yeah come on no no
on the left what's that moving left left
he did top left there this one that's
the way what movie is that that's a
three amigos like three of them be quick
and keep clicking let's see what it was
they were look at the with him with
Mitzi shore Wow yeah look at that photo
let's kill it all with Sam and everybody
looking Freddie look at them is amazing
he had a [ __ ] face that's call a bow
yeah Freddie asparagus
that's [ __ ] yeah Argus oh my god that's
cocaine argue Sam stash Kinnison right
there with the stache and Jim Carrey oh
look at Freddie asparagus how big and
fatty was
but now he was getting lost weight hey
that's the store parking lot with that
IV look at that that's the IV yes
easy Jim Karen and look at that Datsun
b210 right there in the background one
of the comics is driving that well he
was the guys at the store that
befriended me right away like I saw like
after the store I'm like oh my god
[ __ ] Freddie asparagus yeah and he
would talk to many kept saving me and
Andy [ __ ] hate you yet
yeah and I thought him the whole
antithetical broad I met Andy and the
concert Janet Jackson concert when he
was shooting things are doing dead
because I was bad I just didn't go over
Bob
Wow and we started talking and next
thing you know [ __ ] yet he died there's
another some more look at the real deal
he's the real deal Freddie
yeah look in the wood angel Salazar yeah
what angel Salazar happy birthday comedy
star 10th anniversary look at that 10th
anniversary guys you see the guy all the
way at the right behind Argus yeah Argus
his shoulder yeah he was the executive
producer of our list who got me on our
list
oh really yeah he got me on our list
he's a he's a he was one of the look at
angel Salazar when he was date there was
angel right there to the right to the
right to the right right there looks
like he was the one that was in your
office in the office with a son card
oh my god that's angel [ __ ] sounds
oddly Scarface that's when the store was
the [ __ ] store all over smiling
because look at Argus he had a [ __ ]
half a kilo Coakley's oh my god
look at all these pictures they're
[ __ ] yeah those are great look at
that one there it's like orange colored
there right yeah that way you're right
there look at that one let's look at
that Wow look at those Dave Letterman
look at that oh yeah oh man that [ __ ] is
crazy the guy from the improv yeah but
Friedman of Friedman the chick yeah look
at that that's crazy
well that's some good [ __ ] man that's
some comedy gold right there that is I
could look at that [ __ ] for probably
took all right well that first got to
the store especially well oh yeah yeah
oh yeah it's so many pictures they look
at it yeah
oh my god even the guys we know like now
like how much they change like always
photo and and when you look at like the
different eras of different guys you
know like wow is that who is that you
know you're looking at I'm like that's
Steve Rannazzisi you know different guys
they totally look different
it's when you look at those pictures you
go [ __ ] up a part of that anyway you
know yeah I remember looking at those
pictures as an outsider yeah I'm like
I'll never be that cool to be at a party
let's see sure if that's [ __ ] crazy
so cool man
all right nah [ __ ] it sometimes they
have Freddie asparagus he would you know
what it was one of those guys I got to
meet him
talk to him for like a month and a half
and then one day they came and they go
he died Wow what he died from like a
heart attack
oh wow they do the memorial at the store
then he came and I went they played
music at the end this [ __ ] was really
[ __ ] dynamite that's why that was one
of my first kind of like strong memorial
and a real old-time mister I am a lot
old time yeah that was one of the last
time I let him yeah I went to a store I
didn't see him right I didn't see him
but somebody said he came for Freddie
asparagus Wow yeah those guys were tight
those guys were part of it because Andy
Garcia I didn't know nothing about Andy
being a Comedy Store regular did you
know you didn't know that either no I
never knew that come on dawg I swear to
God he was he was a cop him he was a
host on Monday nights I never knew that
he answered the phones Wow
so years ago I forgot who the talent
direct coordinator was I got a call from
somebody going look through your
archives and see if you could find
anything I see his head shots Wow
like Daria trust gets a call or
something yeah and they found it Wow and
they put it on the show
I guess he answered the phones at The
Comedy Store Wow and he did the Monday
night improv group in the main room with
Dave Letterman that's how come Dave and
a my friends Wow on Monday nights they
were all part of that Monday night was
the biggest night store yeah
you're not gonna believe I remember that
I never remember well when I was going
there in 88 AJ's was crazy the whole
town would end up there
did you [ __ ] ever go there on Monday
night's my boy sold blow say to go we'll
hit there he would do a lap around the
store he was dating the head waitress we
drink free and it was just make like
rock boys you were you going for a storm
like 87 holy shait yeah man
sin you know all those guys down there
man there was wild just drunk I'd be
drunk and doing blow you know hanging
out and cuz you know you would go to
like the whiskey and see a band and then
everybody would end up at the store you
know cuz Monday nights at the whiskey I
think was uh just think no bozo Jam and
everybody could play he just signed up
and jammed and then everybody would go
to the store after hang out on the patio
it was like wow my buddy I'll team and I
had him on the podcast because it was
foggy for me because yeah man yeah he
would go through it and tell me I was
dating the waitress your buddy was
dealing to blow I was like wow it's so
crazy you posted a great picture
yourself with a Funko the other day they
use excellent yeah he said something
about Laurel Canyon yeah that was at the
Laurel Canyon mansion right there the
one that Rick Rubin bought where Chili
Peppers did their blood sugar sex Magik
so I was in there and that's where I
kind of OD Don below I was just telling
burr the story it was like 80s and the
guy the guy actually went for a pyramid
of blow yeah he was trying to make like
a pyramid like Scarface style like yeah
and I went over there thinking it was
the blow was gonna go away so I took a
giant massive probably a gremlin not
even knowing and my left arm just froze
up and I was like oh [ __ ] my arm
I don't feel and I went over to the guy
and I got dude you got a call in
hambling it's he's all [ __ ] that up
you go we can't get any heat up here
there and we got [ __ ] a lot of blow
and that's Axl Rose over there playing
piano you
how he's like he just handed me about he
goes either you split or drink it down I
was like oh man all right and I went
over the club's just drinking the stole
he's trying to come down rubbing my arm
like that's gonna help I was rubbing my
arm like a like the doctor you know like
this is what happened and I and it
finally went away after like an hour
oh you know that had to be like some
kind of small stroke or something you
know what I mean and if you look at our
eyes in that photo I'm just pegged just
bad my eyes just cook and now Axl was
what you was this yeah
eighty-eight right there he was already
Axl
oh yeah he's Axl and Matt fact I tell
the story and and the guy backed it up
on my podcast cuz people would be like
oh I don't know about that but got the
photos to prove it he goes do you want
to hear a new song I'm working on they
had a piano there he played November
rain I never forgot it
weird this there was like eight of us
did you see I just broke them ability
can't believe it
did you see what a billion views is it's
so weird that I had bird on here yeah
maybe three years ago and we were gonna
talk about some of them we went into a G
in our fantasy world right the impact of
Guns N'Roses
summer of 88 I would just insane
steamrolled engine it's it it was you
know it was enough enough in the vein of
Elton John in New York City in 73 the
vein of you know Michael Jackson yeah in
84 New York and then the vein of
Springsteen
oh yeah point here is a [ __ ] Jersey
9:19 that vein of Madonna at 85 yeah
like a virgin 88 [ __ ] was just GNR as
[ __ ] destruction and it started slow
over like a Bam Bam Bam but I don't
still never forget their videos yeah and
I don't remember that bird and then I
went into like November rain and the
other one yeah and do you know for six
weeks kids we're emailing me going I
never knew those [ __ ] videos even
exist oh yeah the trilogy like thank you
for even talking about
usually one mother and two tarik how
they destroyed 1990 I think think they
came out over 90 yeah that's two records
in one day Tower Records he's like the
leave Valley it was unbelievable
game-changer game-changer you know it
was so weird to think about how five
dudes were the biggest guys on the
planet from just Hollywood you know what
I mean just [ __ ] huge not did you
know any of them before the explosion I
knew I knew the guys
well my band was playing and they play
San Francisco and then I would see him
in LA my buddy was my buddy actually
played keyboards for him a little bit he
actually played drums one time when
Adler broke is on this guy Howard
teaming who's got a tattoo shop right on
Ventura right now
and the team and brothers there were
three of them they lived in that mansion
and G&R would rehearse there sometimes
you know it'd go up and jam and stuff
and they would have crazy parties at
this place dude crazy two three four-day
runs you know it was just wild and and
how our data an Impala convertible
painted like a cheetah
so you'd see them all overall it oh
there's Howard you know just [ __ ]
these guys ruled the city man now what's
the connection we would like / Laurel
Canyon they all lived a little Kang in
the South like that no I don't know
where they they lived over there by
Guitar Center the hell has right behind
ya right right I'm guarding the bar
those garages exactly behind that not
toy if you go to toy you went too far
right it's behind the or the sunset
grill right exactly it's behind us I
know the song that the eagle sang that's
a grill behind ya he'll trick home yeah
yeah that's all [ __ ] crazy yeah and I
guess across the street somebody else
would got that hole it's rock and roll
it was rock and roll dough nobody else
lived there across the street it was all
harrowing - it's crazy because you get
heroin at an American burger that's
where the guys would hang out oh my god
right now when they did American pimp
yeah they would they show them let's go
back yeah
American burger is [ __ ] poultry now yeah
always [ __ ] now what's the other one
where where if you stand on sunset
that's I yeah and you went down towards
like my rouse yeah there was a hamburger
place yes yes there was a hamburger
joint that was there forever the burgers
are horrible but it was a hooker hangout
I just remember sunset grill and if you
down from the sunset grill if you watch
American pimp I use brothers yeah love
that movie they interview slim what
happened yeah yeah he's the front of
place oh he's not gonna more time coming
down here then yet rock and roll Danny's
rock and ride is rock'n'roll Denny's was
a [ __ ] that was just spot that was a
crazy that one Joey Uncle Joe has read
Oh stories about that [ __ ] SWAT dog
that [ __ ] five block radius was so
dark it was just dope and rock and roll
and [ __ ] lunatic not to beat it up
God rest his soul
Ralph eatos destroy about with the pimp
yeah knocked on his door Wow hostile you
want piece of ass right in that
neighborhood yeah because that
neighborhood when nobody remembers was
the first guy to invade that whole
neighborhood County wise it was a member
named Doug Stanhope oh wow
who still has an apartment then it's
rent control he still has it he will not
give it up whoa that's a little secret
then well I'm well while people don't
know he still has this since 1996 yet in
that area right controlled studies on
curse on oh yeah easy been on curse on
forever because he could walk the coach
and horses
yeah coaching artisans more he stayed
there his breakfast 400 I was in 1998
yeah it's probably 750 now 750 six eight
twenty the corner from the [ __ ]
7-eleven so he never let it go he's kept
it all he's got houses all over the
world
he's kept that apartment Justin [ __ ]
case
that's rad and then he had his mother
next to him uh-huh
oh and the other one well his mother
came out he happened to get what the
German girls there was German girls one
had big tits and the other one had curly
hair and one night she smacked your
rogue in the face
Wow I had a [ __ ] restaurant because
she misunderstood they had an argument
something crazy [ __ ] she went to smack
Joe Rogan a coach and horses but that's
the the did you German sister the
roommate was a coke [ __ ] photographer
[ __ ] crazy Wow she was crazy and Doug
Stanhope would drive her crazy like I
would and then the mother lived next to
Doug when they moved out yeah Doug put
his mother in there that's Fran with
Ralphie Ralphie moved in that building
today off he lived with Doug for a while
Wow so when they dug calmer he goes have
you seen Ralphie you know she's not
gonna let me believe what happened he
was like quantum bear with my mother if
I'm not dressed in two ran out I haven't
seen him since so I went over there yeah
and I get there and they're all laughing
at me they play the [ __ ] prize
Ralphie used to live in that Doug
Stanhope estate that's why we called his
mother god bless her soul her name is
Bonnie yeah but if her name is Bonnie
but we squawk Bonnie earmuffs because
you had to put in more Sun because she
of the beat and she would give you ha ha
you could not get bodies done bonnie was
like my daughter
you get mercy you don't even have to
give mercy a bump of coke yeah she will
talk a hero of a straight sneaky and
quoting herself and argue yourself
no no no no no thing 45 minutes long he
makes mercy look like looks Louisa for
Bonnie a monster face she had nine cats
or a little missing something nine cats
so she would go and take the cat Doug
Stanhope his mother would go save the
cats on execution day Wow she would save
cats that were missing something because
she didn't want them together bring him
back to the hut so she'd have one cat
without alarm one cat one over here
uh-huh
one cabin on the town one cat so we
would go with us that from 97 to 98 I
stay that Stanhope's
two maybe three
for months yeah he bought bunk beds oh
wow that's how cool he was here and put
him in his living room he just said
people don't Olivia wow I saw him last
week at the store I was he's brilliant
yeah and he's so nice man he comes up
Dean what's up man bingo when you were
asleep and you know Dean was on the end
of the world God cast magic oh hey you
know it's just like so nice and cool I
love that guy then he just murders oh
he's special from a few years back just
destroyed at in Portland though in the
50 seat room I told him to his face I
said one of the greatest specials I've
ever seen and it came out like two three
years ago awesome give a [ __ ] no he has
no [ __ ] he doesn't go he's [ __ ] he's
a special type am I just watch them on
Rogen oh yeah I watched my mother love
that cat I've always loved them yeah I
got a two-bedroom and a car Wow that you
could borrow but there was a problem
with the car you got to go right to the
gas station cuz again the gas gauge was
broken oh yeah you know I got in the car
you gotta go right to the gas station
she don't know how is it
it'll be times I ran out of gas at that
[ __ ] car pushing a limit I gotta have
an audition and I didn't have a car when
I first moved out yeah I go to Stan home
I go Doug I'm gonna bind borrow the
[ __ ] car now make sure you put 20 of
it before you even make that right turn
I don't know in the land he jump it for
you and everything here's a special soul
man because you know I I love people
that can just be like that where they
can just be like hey man whatever's mine
is yours and whatever happens happens
you know like there's no rigid nothing
it's just yeah man yeah you know like
when bands roll through and Bisbee they
stay at his place and stuff you know
it's like that's a that's a that's a
that's a a gift that most people don't
have don't have I don't have that gift
yeah I don't have that gift I don't
either because I'm like an only child so
I'm like yeah but over each other I need
to [ __ ] be another gift yeah I don't
know what is it guys normally [ __ ]
guys I come out they don't see [ __ ]
coasters yeah I will have a [ __ ] hard
yeah like a half a beer bottle with a
cigarette in it [ __ ] a heart attack
yeah damn yeah so before Joey has that
heart attack yeah I don't like movement
yeah yeah I don't know movement what do
you move right yeah it stays a week
doesn't get any bring toilet paper come
on you know bring nothing madly nothing
to the plate and here's the Flay thing I
know how to be hospitable with people
like if you come to menu I'm coming out
the hell away I need to stay three days
yeah I'm very hospitable
I'm just not yeah I had Rollins on he
you know what he said you guys I Love
You Man you call me you tell me your
car's broken or whatever I'll come get
you and help you but if you can't say
can I stay at your pad here's $400 get
the best hotel I just don't want people
at my pad yeah I mean it's like yeah
he's I know he's a big he's the only
child to you know it's just something
weird about it [ __ ] you up it does [ __ ]
yeah because I'm very hospitable yeah oh
you come over whatever I'm not gonna
take it universal yeah I'm not gonna
show you no travel sites like my
brothers in San Diego
I love dill he landed time this is what
his you've known me seven years and this
is his fourth or fifth time this is
probably I don't how many times is Comic
Con what Comic Con is every year San
Diego what number is this I don't know
has been coming since day one right I
mean this guy I didn't even know you had
a brother Pete George man ever since
1978 we went we met in summer school and
if he didn't [ __ ] uh if I didn't bump
into him in 1985 I bumped into him I was
casing houses yeah up in Bergen County
he was a lawn mower dude yeah he was
whatever
raking a wad yeah landscape landscape I
bumped into them February of 85 after
not seeing him for like four years we
lost communication Wow pump then told
mistake bumping into somebody in [ __ ]
Redondo Beach you or me like paces yeah
that's
and I called them that night I got
arrested that afternoon when bumpkin
told ya I got arrested three hours later
I had his number in my pocket I called
them up and I go come get me and Bambi
on he bailed me out but he stay in the
hotel let's go get your stuff I talked
to my mom you could stay with us
yeah and he's been my brother since
February of 85 that's just the way life
is
yeah jaws was the wolf is another kind
of stand-up guy like you know how you
let you stay at his pad he's like that
like it whatever you need just come over
take it you know yeah yeah there's some
people that are very generous but I'll
let you stay in my pad yeah
I'm just not gonna go to Universal with
ya I'm not know what my schedule is I do
my [ __ ] that's the problem they do my
[ __ ] yeah you know so there's hours
where I don't even like to talk it's
funny because like we has a friend and
she's very sweet so he says if you ever
go to the coffee shop call me it's the
last thing I want yeah yeah it's the
last thing I wanna drink well when I
look at a coffee shop it's to work yep
it's to get out of my house to get
vitamin D to breathe to ear German to
hear nature to hear birds and cars and
people you know running through red
lights and horns and then I get my
thinking though and I get what's that
word you can't not you get like when you
get like my daughter she sees too many
red lights what happens to it she gets
to she sees to overstimulation mister
below yeah I need that also we all need
that you know I'm saying that's why I
[ __ ] go to a coffee shop I don't know
no coffees you know she'd come over and
talk to me about life yeah coffee I
drink green tea
yeah I'll even drink coffee oh my god I
drink green tea on [ __ ] time it's like
like a coffee shop I go and I sit in the
corner and unplug my phone I take my
computer on I take a notebook on it's
two hours I got a two hour timer
yeah so that two hours I drank a little
bit like I got a two hour time and
outside two hours I get up because it's
not your back start started yeah you
gotta get up and move around
yes yeah there's gotta be something you
schedule an hour work or work out then
you go back afterwards the two hours and
it's a lot easier than sitting there for
four hours nothing's gonna get
accomplished now usually get the taste
of ink in your [ __ ]
and also then you just start [ __ ]
just looking at your phone or whatever
you're like yeah what is holiday yeah
you know it's it's it's I've said on the
show a thousand times how thought is
your enemy and your best friend thought
could be your best friend or your enemy
I know you have to cut a line that
thought at some point because you might
overthink the situation and then come up
with [ __ ] dick or when you don't get
might try to tell people I don't like
close bases like if I had to come here
at 8:00 in the morning like sit here
without the door open I would lose my
mind by 9:30 I've been a bad mood yeah I
would just think about things to set me
off in a bad mood I think about that
time in the eighth grade cheeky she
lonely yeah with Steven the football
playing why would you think about that
now just that's where no stimulation in
the daytime that's why I tell comics to
always have a job yeah man because if
you're hanging out with electronics they
just telling you bad news the daytime
yeah if you live with two or three other
comics will then telling you they're
telling you about what's not happening
yeah horrible yeah and all of a sudden
you get six or seven of those morons
together the black pit and it's the
suicide crew and it's Sunday let's see
who snapped first we've seen it a
thousand times
comics think that you that's why I tell
people you have to have a daytime
schedule yeah man just cuz you don't
have a job don't mean you don't have a
[ __ ] job yeah you sleep all day [ __ ]
now you got a job and a half there's
your help
there's writing there's bills this
contacting people there's always
something you could be doing yeah man
like this always something you could be
doing a lot of people don't know I don't
do that yeah I get up immediately start
doing [ __ ] the gym editor podcast
go get a coffee right listen to the set
then go back try to book some people for
the podcast then you know sell something
on Craigslist whatever I'm doing all day
long just generating move now what the
[ __ ] is it that you sell on Craigslist
can you please tell me I just sold a
bicycle on there and I
so you buy and sell [ __ ] buy and then
flip it yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah man something you know like lately
I've been on the road and I try to hit
some I look for some vintage audio
equipment
you know like stereo stuff that's it's
uh that's it's going for big money man
you know like like that Marantz I got I
bought two of them sold one of them some
mines free you know made like double the
money just whatever I can flip what the
apps 10th day and that was looking at
the quality yeah of that piece of that
never answer it so I was looking at the
quality and I knew that if I walked over
to him I tried to pick it up like a holy
falafel you cook up a DVD it's like a
pound like we moved I got picked up it
was nothing like when I was a kid you
picked up a [ __ ] that receiver oh my
god it was dirty [ __ ] pounds it was
pure [ __ ] metal if you put the ear
plugs when you get here Martian talking
don't you know when I sold the one the
other one to the guy who came and picked
it up he he's a Don Henley's keyboard
player just happened to come over and
offer Craigslist like we need to do is
like keyboards you know and then we
start talking I go I got a podcast he
goes oh I listen to it I know who you
are and they go yeah have played behind
a curtain for the Eagles so you know a
little keyboards here and then I go out
with Don Henley I was like wow he went
over to grab that thing and he this was
like oh I saw that's [ __ ] back like
oh this thing's no joke man probably 85
pounds but it doesn't you're thinking
about this new [ __ ] now that weighs like
an ounce nothing so he went over to grab
at one hand and just took himself out
your shoulder like do you remember when
that was big and then someone who's
wearing a store now just has it at the
wrong price is that what you do know
what as vinyl is starting to get hot you
know again of course in the last few
years you know turntables and the
equipment's get not so you just find
some old good stuff from the 70s
that works you know still that should
work forever
it's a bulletproof man that old [ __ ] and
then you know it just goes up and up in
price just find it like when you're in
Middle America and you're at like a
goodwill gotta go get that this is
[ __ ] my ransom nobody though nobody
knows the cost on this I don't know yeah
25 safe start looking around the thing
you go your thing work yeah I have known
you all day you know we [ __ ] yeah walk
winds are hot right now again cuz people
love cassettes these these hipsters oh
yeah
hipsters are going cassettes right now
know that absolutely those are back now
I saw that the DVD is done done yeah
Don DVD and the CD are done III think I
grew up with a cassette and I didn't
even really maybe that's why played a
part in to why I never really fell in
love with music I used to hate it you
have to fast-forward you don't know what
you're fast-forwarding I know you're
trying to find the track I hate that all
right then the tape gets all stretch
then it eats it you're like [ __ ] with
things gone to eat your cassette you
read that you're you [ __ ] pulling it
out oh there was a certain player that
kept taking cassettes how people get
pissed it was like something you taped
over it would you get pissed
you ever throw your cassette and the
buddies ride like yeah I brought the
tunes and then his ride each your tape
you're like dude you're [ __ ] you owe
me your worries ladies and their 80s
there was a cassette deck yeah blob punk
okay I love that blob came in all the
beamers remember that blob punk if you
fast-forward it I hate your tape oh
that's what it was if you press fast
forward or reversed oh okay like [ __ ]
then you tried to save the tape was 10
bucks on Jim Bob you gotta push it and
then the tape will come out and the more
you pull the tape work the guts will
come on you and and then you had your
illest would take their pans like me and
just break the tape and then they would
[ __ ] the whole thing up but I knew how
to actually take it apart then and drive
her I would roll reel it back in with
him and says wherever it would get
wrinkles yeah I would just rub
nice and pray back and forth like three
hours like a half a homo that I am
there's all sticky mountains oh my god
there's egg Mountain [ __ ] crazy
what'd you do to save your cassettes
what you did get that party to be like
welcome to the I cannot believe the
cassette is coming back let me give some
shot yeah
John Petrowski I love you kitty Forman
you sexy Savage Nate Mooney Yuri Andrews
Andres Nolan Patton all Dewey Robert
gliese dick bird
Mikey Sereno four and dos tres I love
you that's it who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with those tress I love
that [ __ ] name and always little wing
is always Bobby and Sherry's always the
Australian [ __ ] warrior the originals
the church [ __ ] originals Kichi on
the couch don't [ __ ] eat I can't even
look at the you know Sam alright so give
me your top ten live albums okay if your
[ __ ] best friend came to you and said
I want you to recommend your top ten
albums and why alright okay what first
one for number ten is is a record that I
talk about a lot Santana live at the
Fillmore I love this one man a good
psychic I think I got it
it is incredible painting ramble what
year is that I think it's like 69 or oh
my god that that's good one I can't even
believe I greatest all right then this
is another one and last night I I did
the goddamn Comedy Jam saying me and
Maron we did long way to the top if you
want to rock and roll and backstage it
remind me Bob Marley played there and
did a live record Bob Marley live at the
rocks it's funny cuz of somebody I was
talking to somebody they said one of the
Marley albums that's the one live in a
boxing live at the rocks that's the one
it is incredible man the band is at the
top of the game it is like the ultimate
live reggae record it's insane
then Frampton Comes Alive of course
everybody in their mom and that yeah you
know Nugent double live gonzo and I just
had Rollins on my podcast Monday and he
and I talked about seeing Nugent in that
era there's nothing like it
nothing like nothing like it was a story
going around somebody pulled the gun out
and he pulled a bow and arrow some way
some [ __ ] Cobo Hall or something yeah
that was nuts that guy would he come out
with a loin [ __ ] thing oh yeah listen
man he followed Aerosmith yeah no
problem
no I was watching Doug Stanhope and
Rogan yeah somebody said well he's just
a guy who had two shitty song in the 70s
no I think you're mistaken there you
know I do not like Ted after
what's-his-name left no after saying
he's on the road no he's on the road
yeah yeah he's doing something on the
road yeah there's a nice if you like
that out yeah I mean it's 70% Derek st.
Holmes yeah absolutely he is the same as
the singer I didn't even know he was the
singer so I went now is the stranglehold
that we hear yeah the same stranglehold
on double live gonzo no the stranglehold
you mean that they play now yeah oh yeah
it's the same yeah that's from that
album that's from that album absolutely
yes a strangled [ __ ] snow storm
troopers storm troopers just only to
become and get a ready dog dog dog a dog
yeah no it's a it's a brilliant telling
you that that's why I opened up with it
when I heard Wang dang sweet poontang
believable I [ __ ] forgot it I'm like
Nashville 76 and the way he said the
word [ __ ]
yeah he's [ __ ] mentioned that I
remembered that at the end did he blow
it at the end with a 16 year old oh I
don't know man yeah he left with
suddenly there was allegations of
something that she became 18 and it went
away
Wow sister's wife sister whose wives
Wow okay then this one was big big to me
Cheap Trick Budokan yeah that's on
everybody's list dad was
that was a record okay then Ramones it's
alive that's never got into that that
one is yeah that that one is just a
classic live energy punk rock record
just like holy [ __ ] kiss alive - of
course
Zeppelin song remains the same I got
turned on to that but you don't want to
put it on the list like it's too easy
yeah I know bad that's why I told you
I'm not gonna put always yeah there was
albums that were too easy yeah you know
there's so [ __ ] many yeah great you
know we would comparison we were
comparing it to calmly like hard is to
get the perfect shot and let me tell you
something don't get confused a lot of
those shows a different shows from
different night course you edited
together how to live together so let's
not get confused but there are some
performances out there straight throw
straight through yeah [ __ ] How the
West Was run Zeppelin at the LA forum
yes
smokin some open with immigrant song
smoke what a punch in the face okay
Allman Brothers live at the film okay
there's just no again it's too easy yeah
too easy yep it's too easy - that - I
listen to that - but that we've been
posed and there was something else in
there the first song we found himself
how they all Jim how they open see when
I talk about imposing your will like
this would I didn't like when I did my
Netflix special I did impose my will I
let the will get imposed on me right
that's the best way to explain it when
you listen to the Allman Brothers live
at the Fillmore
as a matter of factly find it just for
one second Oh stupid live at the
Fillmore watch what how they open up
yeah it's a do you think that they give
you what catch you want it's how do you
think the Allman Brothers like no more
East yeah yeah on the drive we're all
sitting in the car going they're gonna
hold up with this yeah yeah and they're
gonna open up with that I get how bet
you [ __ ] the joint nice people with a
vision
sound out of Macon Georgia trouble is
the Allman Brothers automaker says they
feel Wanda Mordred is growing as Bill
Graham listen to it yeah listen to this
music who opens up with this the Allman
Brothers do it's their terms
way
who opens up like this this is bed
service
come on
are you [ __ ] kidding me
dirty white from the heart
no fakeness at all a little kiss zero
and then a zero [ __ ] given murdering oh
here we go Blaine
no no he won't sing he won't say a lot
sticky in this other guy rock this
very Oakley [ __ ] believable
squawking firmer
you think they give a [ __ ] about Twitter
didn't give a [ __ ] about snapchat
nothing nothing what a great [ __ ] out
no well again when I put this Alma yeah
it's like I'm boring you to death
yeah but I tried it I tried not to put a
little bit look at the guy that did the
movie with Pryor yeah we were pride was
his name Gene Wilder
yeah general hunter and Johnson that guy
killed himself a couple years ago 1970
that's 540 [ __ ] eight years ago I
walked by that venue almost every day
over New York everyone gonna be ok look
at that day I do this I look cross I
walk right by every time I see everybody
into the sign of the Cross because this
is a totally a st. Patrick's Cathedral
baby hi it's God has been there that
one's been in there East everybody's
been in there yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
what else is on your list okay Wow just
do very quickly why do you guys like why
is it too easy for you if you like it
that much why why can't it well it's an
obvious one because most people love it
but it has the magnitude of it is so
insane to me that I have to I have to
[ __ ] say it there's just no way
around it okay so what I don't feel more
East yeah well I had that number seven
yeah yeah one for the road let us get it
whoo easy okay
Frampton Comes Alive too easy yeah saw
remains the same too easy right then I
come up with false in prison okay I love
I love the first three [ __ ] jams how
he broke it down I got kiss alive on
there awesome my number four is live at
Budokan and I don't like cheap trick oh
yeah that's the record okay I don't even
like cheap trick I made me [ __ ]
talking about [ __ ] cheap trick no no
no and I'm telling you live at Budokan
then my number three is unleashed in the
East which we're going to talk about
something else also my number two which
I think and I'm not a big [ __ ] big
purple fan but made in Japan is a bad
[ __ ] and I'm gonna tell you a
shot I'm that I loved
under the blood red sky Oh
at Red Rocks see there you go
[ __ ] rainbow on stage yeah
yes songs you know to capture what yes
was doing live yes was doing something
they had too many moving pieces it was
like Chicago yeah oh yeah how goes a
great band moving pieces yeah but what's
that one but I put up with Chicago just
had some [ __ ] [ __ ] masterpieces I
hated Chicago thrown out and then my
buddy turned me on to Chicago three I
was like wow cuz this no it's like a
[ __ ] war
and then they came back in 83 yeah man
now 84 would ya Peter Cetera
that's a jam that he's saying right
we're smoking came back ten years late
and broke the bank ah you found someone
else
oh yeah didn't have no reason yeah no
one can blame you for running to him all
that [ __ ] two people together that's the
[ __ ] that's the [ __ ] yeah oh my god
alright so that you know I got Metallica
S&M yeah man
alright like I said I got yes song that
run what really killed me about my list
that I had it like I said I never did
this much homework in a long time was
that five out of my ten house was shot
in [ __ ] Maine Japan Unleashed Ernie's
live at Budokan West kiss a live shot
kiss alive I think some states I know
that's Cobo Hall okay yeah so for those
albums yeah like three or four of those
albums that were shot overseas because
I'll tell you you know and we've even
talked about UFO again strain too easy
we already beat that up beat that up we
beat that I even start to tell you how
good if you want blood I can't even tell
you you got it it's the best if you want
blood you got it was the one that got me
back into all these life saying yeah and
now I feel bad now I feel shitty because
when I gave those albums away in 84 I
had over three or four hounds in there
but I probably had over a hundred of
those live recordings I would buy from
the guard oh yeah and I gotta be honest
a let's be honest the truth as a hundred
forty of them with Donal that's when you
know sometimes you have bad tapings
audience recording audience recordings
under the stage some night you really
yeah that's what I heard like what they
do is they pay some the guy the security
guys and they come in early and they
just put some mics under the stage you
know and then split and then come back
get the recording later so they're under
the stage or they'd sneak them in under
seats tape it under a seat you're
sitting under a tape recorder you don't
even know you think while you get the
one guy yeah yeah you get beat all the
[ __ ] time on those but every once in
a while
yeah you know where the Masters are
taping those deadheads know they're the
best deadheads are the genius last day
we used to get some deadhead [ __ ] in
Boulder yeah you can't even believe it
the matter of fact the band puts them
out now you know like like they put them
out like Dix picks and all they like you
know they get a good one they go we're
putting this out do you know I just
heard what I [ __ ] heard that just
singer from Bad Company yeah
Jeff Beck yeah and Nancy Wilson on yeah
they're on tour they're playing the
Greek but listen to this yeah what night
I don't know but I know the planet yeah
let's see that let's go down have you
seen Paul Rodgers at that way good
singing ah he's so great did I saw I saw
the firm [ __ ] phenom I saw the firm
Joan you see him with Queen singing no
no did you see him with Quinn I didn't
see him I saw him on video but not live
the vh1 thing yeah with the wig on yeah
yes those is Tina
here's the deal with them you go Sam by
the time you get home and you buy the
concert online it's not rad it's gonna
download it yeah $1 yeah download the
show live from [ __ ] whatever that was
the one you're at $1 that's that's the
way to go yeah $1 right on your webpage
stays it tape professionally and you
want the shows these are like
underground [ __ ] comedy show yeah
yeah tape that's it done that's a new
idea we're gonna do I'd like to do a
crowd worked or like you know and then
just tape it every night give it away
here's the night you were there you know
a lot of people remember that 20 years
ago [ __ ] Pearl Jam got penalized
big-time oh yeah they got spanked and
they were only allowed to do like three
shows per tour yeah well they were
playing no Ticketmaster and no
Ticketmaster rooms but what they would
duel is I think in 98 they Cornell
shares
yeah and they put them all out I put
them all out yeah he would walk into a
music store maybe like 40 around bag
around back every that [ __ ] dynamite
you going and go you know what leave one
in Nashville
nan said the show was phenomenal I could
buy the [ __ ] album right a direct
assault different setlist every night
every setlist every day Pro did you have
to you know I like what - nails is doing
this year yeah
making the fans go down and buy the
tickets I love making the floor [ __ ]
experience there I gotta tell you
something this is it like for me guys
this is it what I went through with this
last half-hour
taping yeah I'm done you're done I'm
done
I'm never taping nothing another special
again is that right I'm only doing out
oh wow oh yeah cuz you love because you
make great money on them right it's not
the money yeah it's not the money you
know what man I'm a [ __ ] old
fashioned stubborn [ __ ] yeah and
what I like I like and there's certain
things that piss me off like that
there's certain parts of technology that
piss me off because I think that people
are missing chunks of their lives from
that
dan oh we laugh at the people in the 50s
that would sit there listen to a
greenhorn on the radio right you don't
even see those pictures normal America
doesn't even know what that's like
yeah to sit with your sister your mom
and your dad a fellow the [ __ ] radio
and you listen and listen your brains
work and listen I love the gift of
listening and so many [ __ ] people
ruin it
they ruin it on purpose you ever been
somewhere and you're with somebody and
they think that they have to talk yeah
yeah yeah yeah like there's no something
like an uber I'm not saying I'm
communist but there's no sighs in this
room let's say we need to talk yeah but
there's certain situations that
sometimes you want that peace of mind
yeah but there's certain people that
think they need to talk they're
comfortable in the silence yeah it's not
to get attention to nothing but I'm not
saying it that way just just to tell you
something that has nothing no bearing in
your [ __ ] life at all like it
wouldn't [ __ ] matter to you at all
they break your silence in it it kills
me what the technology has taken away
the gift of listening yeah you know when
I meet someone like Keith you listeners
to podcasts she actually takes the time
to listen yeah it's a gift it really is
a gift it's a gift like I got all those
prior albums like I can't wait to come
in here and get high oh yeah and put on
[ __ ] you know what is something I
said in the beginning oh listen to the
skips in the album the album is dirty is
or will you want some come on you wanna
[ __ ] perfection they're not gonna
have it but to hear that when you listen
let me tell you some left licks is
releasing how many specials 47 one so
what could we have in here yeah would
not the special business is done after
this I don't ever want to shoot a
special again yeah nobody's gonna want
to see a special now they wanna see
something different
the countries where do you see something
different yeah
whoever does it first is gonna win yeah
you do in 30 minutes and 28 and 60
that's great but now if they released 47
them we're gonna be bogged up for a long
time watching [ __ ] special so to get
your eyes off those specials you gotta
do something yeah
so these live album you're talking about
were they you're saying that they
weren't they were like the album but
they just how they recorded an entire
tour and they would take the best take
right each song of you so no best takes
is just that show that night went out
it's one Pro Jam did it when the
deadhead did it now it's that show that
night done that's it that's the way runs
some bands when they put now them
together they record a few night they
record a few nights they take this song
from that just like comics do it yeah
problems we'll take two shows on one
night and take the best from both shows
it's no [ __ ] different they address
the same only you you can't tell you
can't tell right it makes more sense to
eat especially if you're just gonna be
an audio recording of an entire tour I
give it I got stoned and speaking of
stand-up wasn't watching a Stanhope
special I wrote him a long email like
why do you only have two chances to
shoot a special that's crazy it's just
so expensive now yeah it's less
expensive than it used to be but it's
still too expensive to shoot video
what's an ordeal you know compared of an
audio now you just do every night with
your zoom you just bring it on the road
you know I take nine nights there's
nothing better than walking off the
stage yeah that you just destroyed that
[ __ ] stage and you get your stuff and
you took your pictures and somebody taps
you on the shoulder says you want the
sets from tonight and I like you baby
don't they're like yeah and you're like
oh my god thank you because that's what
happens people missed me all the time
the greats of the greats caused a great
added I'm not one of the greats for a
reason I can't do those Babar I did it
would see so I had two mistakes yeah
we'd see so and win definitely
wasn't my best I don't think I think you
know they just sent the final cut
yes at the Sun and you don't like it I
don't know what this thing yeah I don't
like looking at me yeah you follow me
like I don't like we're going me lonely
listen to me you're making me watch me
yeah that's gonna really [ __ ] piss me
off
just make me watch a [ __ ] tampon
commercial my grandmother in the room
with embarrass me more that you know how
embarrassing it is to watch yourself oh
that's worse cuz you're less you ever
knew I did that yeah unless you know
unless you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah like isn't Megan nobody wants
to see themselves I don't want to see
myself ever yeah look at the picture we
took together that's right a little
[ __ ] pay she took the other how long
were you looking at I see a [ __ ] hole
written we [ __ ] break yeah that's it
I don't see nothing else you know yeah
we're so you go to Montreal this year
yeah can you believe in graduation to
what shows are you doing I'm doing the
stand-up on the spot
Jeremias show okay I'm in front of that
then I'm doing think something the dirty
show or something with some show and
then I'm shooting the lol show for Kevin
Hart so that's cool man I'm going up
there next week congratulations
yeah thank when do you leave Thursday
the 26th watch how many [ __ ] church
Canadian fans are gonna come [ __ ] and
get you next Thursday I'm gonna be in
Utah oh yeah almost sold out yeah cuz
you asked me to go and then I was like
[ __ ] I'm going to jfl I would have done
that Utah in a minute and yes a few
tickets laughs yeah was gay wise guys in
Utah fat there's my Dean it's always a
play this was I was so fun right this
was like I said this list was it was I
had to do a lot of thought yeah I really
had to think about what I was blue my
wig and I'm lit a stump
I'm sure I missed yeah there was uh I
got whale with us there was a mic will
shake the live at Budokan oh yeah yeah
yeah there was yeah right like a
political app came up I'm gonna let the
two a galleon John Kelly the Frog you
never gave back to me knock suck nice to
remember the fog in 83 yeah
but he got me cuz he used to bartend
when they read turnaround we throw ice
cubes at him he's gonna quit he would
leave the bar come on when I gotta throw
a little wife
if anybody throws at me I swear to god
I'm gonna walk he turned a the ice cubes
will get thrown out of [ __ ] yeah but I
left them the Albie never gave it back
to me [ __ ] that [ __ ] alright
wiseguys next weekend and then me and
Dean will be at the Kansas City improv
August 9th 10th and 11th [ __ ] get
your tickets I want to crack
congratulate you from the bottom of my
heart for achieving Montreal Comedy
Festival can't believe they know people
always you know I have my crew man I
have my crew young killers that I love
and I back you because I see what you're
doing yeah you know yeah yeah you guys
are out there every night making it
happen not complaining not crying not
[ __ ] you know there's people who are
doing it but they complaining the whole
time yeah well they crying you're out
there you feel [ __ ] my age
yeah I can't be out more than three
nights in a row past midnight I'll turn
into a [ __ ] pumpkin right now I want
to say and you're [ __ ] out there so
my heart goes out there 55 to go to
[ __ ] Montreal yeah yeah and I'll
[ __ ] swing these youngsters with no
testosterone you will work boots on and
[ __ ] yeah I'll give you props man I'm
proud of you and go to Montreal [ __ ]
them up and I'll see you when you come
back and we'll go up to [ __ ] Kansas
City eat some barbecue like those
[ __ ] on fire at the improv and
then we're going to Boston me your
league then we're going to Boston Wilbur
in September why which is got maybe
another 50 tickets left for the second
show I mean cry baby
the first one is completely sold out the
nine in the night there was nine tickets
holding on for dear life yeah they were
like Lee's button the middle yeah yeah
there was lots of deal life nine [ __ ]
Momo's bought those tickets they all sit
in separate but they bought them they
said [ __ ] it we'll go by ourselves great
man I can't even think about that I have
to like imagine it's not you know what
I'm doing to you that are you bad
[ __ ] I want to thank Dean I
want to thank the [ __ ]
but most important well I thank you guys
want to thank kishi I want to thank you
guys for [ __ ] having our backs and
listening and
listen to whatever stupidity we got to
talk about like I said next week Dean
will be in Montreal check is a website
out don't forget to listen to part two
of Henry Rollins Henry Rollins is coming
on our podcast a week or so before the
Showtime thing
hopefully you know we're gonna talk
about storytelling and stuff to yours
and I'm gonna crisscross yeah I think
he's doing Rogen's also but uh
congratulations again the Montreal
I'll see you [ __ ] bring that
Mormon reefer yeah the [ __ ] that makes
you have nine wives you [ __ ] and I'll
see you while the [ __ ] is in Utah I'll
see you guys next Monday more than ready
to rock and roll
stay black have a great week uncle Joey
loves you take care happy birthday Leigh
happy birthday